la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y
en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sur les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour rappelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est retransmis
sur Public Sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun sera attentif
au cours des échanges au respect à la
fois des uns et des autres et du temps
de parole
je vais donner la parole au président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen monsieur le Président vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique les
déboires de la silicom valley-banque la
signature banque nous renvoie au mauvais
souvenir de la crise financière de 2008
c'est effrayant sont rapidement affolés
les marchés suscite à une crainte chez
les citoyens américains qui ne feraient
pas voir exporter chez nous en Europe
depuis quelques jours que ce soit à
Bruxelles par la voie du ministre des
Finances de la zone euro ou par celle de
Jo Bayonne aux États-Unis les
commentaires se multiplient pour
affirmer que l'on doit garder confiance
certes la réserve américaine des trésor
se sont mobilisés pour éviter le pire
certes en Europe les règles
prudentielles sont durci au cours de
cette dernière décennie en jouant sur
les niveaux de solidité et de liquidité
de nos banques je me demandais voilà la
première ministre si elle existe moins
de risques systémiques au sein de
l'Union européenne car le reconnaître
serait l'encouragé c'est bien le
problème des marchés financiers pas le
seul d'ailleurs la célérité s'alimente
des déclarations à l'armiste certes si
on peut espérer que l'incendie soit
éteint car c'est bang run américaines
interrogent quant aux effets de la
politique monétaire menée par les
banques centrales depuis plusieurs mois
la remontée des taux d'intérêts
principal bouchons le coin c'était pas à
montrer ses limites pendant ce temps nos
concitoyens en particulier les plus
modestes souffrent de plus en plus
d'inflation nous sommes à la veille de
la réunion du Conseil des millionnaire
de Max central européen doit-on
s'attendre à une nouvelle hausse des
taux au risque de restreindre encore la
liquidité du système si oui pensez-vous
que les banques françaises soient
suffisamment capitalisées et à mesure de
continuer à jouer le rôle de prêteur
auprès des entreprises et des
particuliers tout cela dans une
situation économique européenne dégradée
pour vous répondre la parole de ta
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Jean-Claude Roquier les
raisons de la faillite de la banque
californienne SVB sont bien connus une
exposition au sol secteur de la
technologie une capitalisation
insuffisante et un manque de fonds
propres une supervision défaillante
cette situation a amené des autorités
américaines apprendre immédiatement les
dispositions nécessaires pour stabiliser
la situation
et je vous confirme comme le ministre
des Finances la Rapée hier que les
banques françaises ne sont exposées à
aucun risque à la suite de la faillite
de la SVB elle respecte des exigences de
fonds propres et de liquidité parmi les
plus fortes au monde elles sont soumises
à une supervision européenne elles ont
des activités diversifiées plus proche
de nous s'agissant du Crédit Suisse dans
les difficultés sont connues de longues
dates je tiens à rappeler que cette
banque n'appartient pas à la zone euro
elle n'est pas soumise donc à la
supervision bancaire européenne et le
ministre des Finances aura un contact
avec son homologue Suisse dans les
prochaines heures ce sujet est du
ressort des autorités suisses et doit
être réglée par elle donc vous le voyez
nous sommes très vigilants mais la
situation est très différente de celle
que nous avons connues en 2008 depuis
des nombreuses règles prudentielles ont
été prises pour toutes les banques de la
zone euro je vous remercie
aujourd'hui la guerre à l'Ukraine
espérons que demain nous l'aurons pas
une crise financière en économie
cavaillère la confiance ne se décrète
pas elle se perd en litres mais ne se
gagne qu'en goutte
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Mélanie
Vogel pour le groupe écologique
solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui serait la journée de
l'apaisement après des années de
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
avec toutes les forces politiques un
consensus sur l'avenir du travail et sur
notre système de retraite aurait été
trouvé et la réforme des retraites
serait en voie d'être adoptée largement
et paisiblement c'est le modèle
décisionnel de tous les pays européens
que vous aimez tellement prendre en
exemple mais pas ici oh parce qu'ici
c'est la France et qu'en France le
gouvernement aime avoir raison tout seul
en écoutant personne et en agissant
contre tout le monde et qu'importe à son
avis que personne ne soit d'accord avec
lui car personne monsieur le ministre
personne sauf une partie des
républicains n'est d'accord avec vous
vous êtes tout seul 75% de la société
française est contre cette réforme 93%
des actifs
aucun syndicat aucun syndicat ne défend
votre réforme même la majorité
parlementaire n'est pas certaine et
pendant que les Français sont encore
massivement dans la rue cette députée
qui n'ont jamais voté ni même étudié
tout le texte et cette sénateur et
sénatrice à qui le gouvernement a imposé
un vote bloqué ont décidé à huis clos de
prendre deux ans de repos au plus
précaires
et vous à ce moment-là vous hésitez
entre une majorité de quelques voix
arrachées contre un pays transformé en
poudrière ou le 49-3 c'est à dire
l'adoption sans vote d'une réforme
minoritaire ces deux options monsieur le
ministre ces deux options sont une folie
ce n'est pas parce que des outils sont
légaux que leur utilisation est légitime
constitutionnels qu'ils répondent au
standard démocratique moderne des
démocraties dignes de ce nom arrêtez les
frais à ce stade de tension sociale et
démocratique l'urgence franchement c'est
plus la réforme des retraites l'urgence
est de sortir de ce fonctionnement
mortifère et d'organiser
démocratiquement la transition vers une
république vraiment parlementaire
pour vous répondre la parole est à
au ministre du Travail de l'Emploi de
l'insertion Monsieur dussoff Vous AVEZ
LA PAROLE merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
mesdames la sénatrice Vogel au fond si
j'ai bien compris votre question est
plutôt qu'une question c'était une
interpellation vous considériez
pratiquement que nous ne sommes pas dans
une dans une démocratie moderne or nous
sommes dans une démocratie moderne nous
sommes dans une démocratie qui permet
l'expression des oppositions qui permet
l'expression des divergences et les
mobilisations que vous avez évoquées en
sont la démonstration les plus flagrante
elle permet l'expression des divergences
et elle permet l'expression des
oppositions dans la limite du respect de
l'ordre public et respecter leur droit
public c'est à la fois éviter les
débordements les organisations
syndicales le font très bien pour
l'organisation des manifestations mais
respectez l'ordre public c'est aussi
condamné les coupures sauvages les
coupures d'électricité qui visent les
permanences et les habitations des élus
dans des sénateurs c'est éviter et c'est
condamné aussi les coupures qui mettent
en danger les commerces les
établissements scolaires les
administrations qui mettent en danger
celles et ceux qui sont capitaliser chez
eux et qui ont besoin d'électricité pour
des respirateurs ou pour des appareils
médicaux et puis respecter l'ordre
public c'est d'une certaine manière
respectée le fonctionnement nos
institutions nous sommes au Sénat et
j'ai eu le plaisir de passer avec vous
ici même 10 jours de débat 10 jours
pendant lesquels le Sénat a pu évoquer
chacun des articles chacune de
dispositions vous nous dites madame la
sénatrice il y a eu un vote unique oui
comme sur la réforme de 2010 ici même
comme sur la réforme de 2013 à
l'Assemblée nationale comme sur la loi
pour la sécurisation de l'emploi c'est
une procédure constitutionnelle qui a un
objectif et un mérite qui est de
contourner l'obstruction parce que si
nous nous posons la question il y a eu
obstruction l'obstruction au Sénat n'a
pas été de la même nature que celle de
l'Assemblée nationale mais il y a eu
obstruction vous avez méthodiquement par
le dépôt de presque 9000 amendements et
sous amendement voulu paralyser le Sénat
et vous lui retirez au Sénat sa capacité
à délibérer la majorité du scénar le
gouvernement ont su répondre pour
permettre aussi de se prononcer et
samedi soir le Sénat a adopté la réforme
orme adopter la réforme avec toutes ses
dispositions et je forme le veut bien
évidemment que la commission mixte
paritaire permettent de trouver un texte
de consensus entre l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat merci
la parole est à
notre collègue Danny whiteblade pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues laissez-moi
vous lire une lettre d'un salarié de
l'usine Bitoni à Caudry LED à son
employeur le groupe Nestlé
courant mars 2022 j'apprends que toute
la production d'une pizza est rappelée
par Nestlé mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est inquiétant on me demande de rester
chez moi
j'apprends que le fruit de mon travail
aurait handicapé et tué des enfants
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait je suis aussi
père je suis rempli de honte et je
pleure le soir je vais reçu du coin en
famille où tout le monde me connaît
à mon arrivée quelqu'un m'interpelle
voilà ça tient de chez Bitoni je ne
réponds pas nous partons
les chaînes d'info nous accables comment
les salariés pouvaient travailler dans
des conditions ils sont sales c'est bien
fait pour eux
je me demande pourquoi Nestlé ne prend
pas la parole pour dire que ses employés
ne sont pas responsables de ce drame
début janvier après une fermeture
administrative et le touage complet du
site les activités reprennent mais les
commandes les commandes sont pas au
rendez-vous la direction suspend la
production et arrête la fermeture du
site voilà monsieur le ministre en
quelques mots la détresse que vive
depuis 12 mois les 150 employés de ligne
de Caudry la même semaine on annonce la
fermeture de l'usine Tereos à
escaudoeuvre avec de nouveau 150 emplois
menacés cette usine proie du sucre une
des filières d'essence française mais à
force d'appliquer de façon drastique
plus drastique que nos voisins les
normes nous sommes en train de détruire
notre filière betteravière alors que le
gouvernement parle de
réindustrialisation des territoires
malheureusement je peux d'avance vous
annoncer que d'autres fermetures vont
suivre
sont des normes coups de massue pour le
cambrésil et le code rési territoire des
gens en grande difficulté aussi Monsieur
le Ministre quels moyens entendez-vous
déployer pour sauvegarder ses usines
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'Industrie Monsieur Roland Lescure de
la parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs les sénateur monsieur
le sénateur wanted d'abord merci d'avoir
rappelé avec émotion réelle les mots que
moi aussi j'ai entendu lundi quand nous
étions ensemble à Caudry pour rencontrer
les salariés de cette usine qui vous
l'avez dit ont pris comme un coup de
massue l'annonce de la suspension
d'activité de la chaîne de production et
surtout ont pris comme une énorme
injustice les accusations qui finalement
leur ont été portées depuis un an
certains ont été traités vous l'avez dit
d'assassin alors qu'évidemment ils ne
sont en aucun cas responsables du drame
sanitaire qui a affecté l'usine de
production Bitoni il y a maintenant un
an ils n'en sont pas responsables et
donc il est hors de question qu'il soit
les victimes collatérales de ce drame
sanitaire j'ai rencontré la direction
mes équipes travaillent avec la
direction du groupe Nestlé pour trouver
d'autres solutions je souhaite qu'on
produise sur l'usine de Caudry des
pizzas à autre chose mais je souhaite
qu'on produise et je ferai tout pour
vous l'avez dit cette cette nouvelle
extrêmement difficile c'est accompagné
d'une autre nouvelle elle aussi vraiment
triste à côté écho d'oeuvre de la part
de terroriste qui a décidé de fermer une
de ses usines vous le savez vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs ça arrive et ça peut
arriver encore à l'avenir des fermetures
d'usine ça arrive mais pas quand une
entreprise gagne de l'argent alors que
l'on perdait à quelques années pas quand
une entreprise se désendette alors
qu'elle était endettée il y a quelques
années pas quand d'une entreprise
bénéficie d'un prix du sucre au plus
haut et d'un marché en pleine expansion
j'ai demandé des explications la
direction nous avons une rencontre
demain vous y êtes conviés avec le
préfet et la direction et les élus parce
que je souhaite qu'on ait des
explications très précises sur les
raisons pour laquelle une entreprise qui
marche une entreprise qui va mieux faire
une usine avec un impact très important
dans la région par ailleurs je l'ai dit
lundi avec vous dans le territoire je le
redis aujourd'hui nous avons déployé
d'ores et déjà annoncé le déploiement de
3 millions d'euros dans le cadre du
programme rebond industriel
qui va permettre aux entreprises
industrielles du territoire qui
souhaitent investir et il y en a de
pouvoir les accompagner dans la
réindustrialisation du territoire le
Nord va mieux monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur il y a des giga Factory à une
heure ou deux heures de Caudry qui monte
et qui vont créer des milliers d'emplois
nous ne devons pas pour autant
abandonner les territoires délaissés
dans le vôtre nous serons à vos côtés
merci
la parole est
notre collègue Jean-François Husson pour
le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie
depuis plusieurs années nous ne cessons
d'appeler votre attention sur l'absence
de maîtrise de la dépense publique
un constat qui est partagé par la Cour
des comptes qui vient de vous adresser
une sévère mise en garde pour ne pas
dire un carton rouge elle dénonce parce
que
quand évidemment
défalqués des exceptionnelles liées à la
crise sanitaire à l'inflation la dépense
publique continue de dériver monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
la France détient bien le niveau le plus
élevé des dépenses publiques en Europe à
hauteur de 58% de notre PIB et Monsieur
le Ministre comment avez-vous pu laisser
ainsi dériver nos comptes publics
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique Monsieur le Maire
je connais votre attachement monsieur le
sénateur Husson pour rétablissement des
finances publiques donc j'espère que
vous me suivrai dans la méthode que nous
avons proposé qui nous a permis en 2018
de revenir sous les 3% de déficit public
de rétablir les Comptes publics et de
sortir la France la procédure pour
déficit excessif cette méthode c'est
d'abord un objectif ramener les dépenses
publiques de 57 à 50 pour 4% des
dépenses qui suppose que tout le monde
fasse un effort et qu'on s'absienne de
déposer des propositions qui peuvent
augmenter la dépense publique mais qu'on
fasse des propositions pour réduire la
dépense publique
3 % de déficit repasser sous ces 3% dès
2027 et réduire la dette publique à
partir de 2026 voilà les chiffres que
nous vous proposons nous proposons aussi
une méthode pour atteindre ces objectifs
une revue des dépenses publiques comme
cela n'a jamais été engagé dans notre
pays consistant à regarder toutes les
dépenses publiques de toutes les
administrations y compris en accord avec
elle celle des collectivités locales
celle des associations celle de l'État
parce que la dépense publique c'est 50%
de dépenses sociales 30% de dépenses de
l'État 20% de dépenses des collectivités
locales et qu'il faut donc que chacun
puisse participer à cet engagement
collectif sur la base d'un diagnostic
qui doit être partagé nous ferons
ensuite un séminaire sous l'autorité
d'après un ministre pour examiner les
dépenses de l'État et nous assurer que
chaque ministère contribue bien à la
réduction à dépenses publiques je
proposerai à toutes les collectivités
locales de participer également à cet
échange et de s'engager dans cette
direction là dans le respect de la
liberté d'administration des
collectivités locales et nous ferons la
même chose pour les associations et nous
aurons des Assises des finances
publiques avant l'été qui nous
permettront d'établir le calendrier et
le montant de réduction de la dépense
s'agissant du calendrier je le redis
notre objectif il est très simple dès le
projet de loi de finance 2024 nous
aurons des réductions significatives de
nos dépenses publiques pour tenir les
objectifs que je vous propose de
soutenir monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur ils sont
monsieur le ministre en septembre
dernier vous aviez annoncé quels
allaient être les dépenses et puis vous
aviez confié le travail à votre majorité
pour trouver des économies vous avez
rendu une copie blanche c'est à dire 0
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui
entraîner aussi doctement que vous le
présentez à l'instant votre finalement
votre méthode et votre stratégie jamais
la France depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale n'a connu un tel niveau
d'endettement
est-ce vrai ou faux c'est juste une
réalité nous allons emprunter 270
milliards d'euros c'est du jamais vu
cette année en 2023 avec des taux
d'intérêts qui remontent donc on se
retrouve en grande difficulté la France
se retrouve en difficulté au moment où
nos partenaires européens ont eux
conduit un certain nombre d'efforts
nous sommes en queue de Plotton sur un
certain nombre de grands indicateurs
d'être Public Record prélèvement
obligatoire record déficit public qui
nous mettent sur le podium européen
envolée du déficit commercial ça ne peut
pas durer c'est l'affaire des Français
monsieur le ministre je l'ai dit vous
avez pris finalement un carton rouge et
la France par contre ne peut pas être
hors-jeu elle ne peut pas rester hors
jeu alors monsieur le ministre à Caen
des économies
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Dominique Verrien pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
madame la ministre la Terre est-elle
plate cette question vous paraît absurde
et pourtant certaines voix estiment
qu'après tout toutes les affirmations
aussi complotistes et farfelues
soient-elles mérite d'être débattues
pire encore comme je l'ai entendu sur
France Inter hier matin elle devrait
être considérée comme des thèses
minoritaires comme les autres qui
seraient donc des thèses majoritaires
elles auraient ainsi leur place dans le
débat public aux côtés de fait
scientifiquement validées un mélange des
genres particulièrement dangereux aux
conséquences parfois désastreuses en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
où certains vous expliquent que le
cancer se soigne par le jeûne ou que les
vaccins sont un outil de contrôle mental
des populations des charlatans profitent
de certains pour leur vendre des
pseudothérapies
inefficaces et dangereuses quand elles
conduisent à un refus de soins
conventionnels des stratégies
pernicieuses qui sous le prétexte du
bien-être mettent peu à peu leur victime
sous emprise et les entraînent dans un
engrenage sectaire qui peut devenir
mortel l'un d'entre eux a été récemment
mis en examen mais n'est-ce pas l'arbre
qui cache la forêt et que dire des
mutuelles qui rembourse des médecines
dites alternatives sans contrôle sérieux
madame la ministre l'État est-il
suffisamment armé pour lutter notre
position vis-à-vis de ces dérives
sectaires quasiment unique au monde
peut-être se conjuguer efficacement avec
la législation européenne
pour vous répondre la parole tu as la
secrétaire des tâches chargée de la
citoyenneté madame Sonia paquet
d'abord je vous remercie d'avoir
participé à ces assises qui étaient
extrêmement riches et un moment
important et attendu par tous cette
toutes ces personnes qui défendent les
victimes et ses dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont touchées chaque année
par ces dérives sectaires effectivement
ces assises ont fait l'objet d'un
certain ont donné un certain nombre de
propositions et la première d'entre
elles c'est la question de la prévention
comment nos compatriotes peuvent-ils
croire de la même manière le fait
scientifique que un certain nombre de
croyances et pour répondre à ça nous
avons eu des engagements forts de la
secrétaire d'État Sarah et l'aéri sur le
travail qu'on a à faire en matière
d'éducation à l'information de nos plus
jeunes pour lesquels finalement on a pas
forcément
évoluer du passage de l'information
traditionnelle au réseau sociaux un gros
travail qui va être mené avec les
plateformes pour éviter que celle-ci
contribue à soutenir
c'est ces dérives là et puis un gros
travail de communication et puis après
il y a un travail particulier en matière
de santé à effectuer puisque on sait
très bien que l'explosion de ces dérives
se passe surtout en matière de santé et
il y a une annonce forte qui a été faite
pardon par le ministère de la de la
santé par la voix de Agnès Firmin le
Baudot avec l'encadrement absolument
indispensable des pratiques non
conventionnelles de soins puisqu'en fait
nos compatriotes ont accès à tout un tas
de praticiens de naturopathe qui pour
lesquelles les pratiques ne sont
absolument pas vérifiées et puis il y a
tout un travail pardon d'accompagnement
des victimes qui attendent une
indemnisation et puis un travail de
sur les auteurs puisque les auteurs
doivent être plus sévèrement punis vous
l'avez dit il y a des mises en examen il
y a des condamnations mais on a besoin
de renforcer notre arsenal pénal et je
compte sur vous les parlementaires et
ici au Sénat en particulier pour
soutenir ce renforcement de notre
arsenal législatif pour condamner ces
gourous et ses charlatans je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
de votre réponse effectivement
effectivement l'arsenal pénal et
peut-être à renforcer en France mais je
crois que il faut réellement travailler
sur la suggestion sur l'emprise et
savoir convaincre probablement aussi la
CEDH que une personne sous emprise n'est
pas une personne libre que si on a
effectivement toute liberté parce que de
choisir une religion c'est un droit
fondamental il faut savoir que subir une
suggestion par contre peut-être un vrai
danger mortel
merci
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente ici pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste ils
avaient la parole madame la Présidente
merci
hier vous affirmiez devant les députés
que chacun devait assumer ses choix je
vous demande donc aujourd'hui d'assumer
les vôtres celui du coup de force
anti-démocratique celui de la régression
sociale depuis deux mois le peuple vous
dit non les grèves et manifestations se
multiplient sur tout le territoire et
demeure ce qu'elles ont toujours été des
outils du progrès social hier vous avez
répondu avec nervosité à mon ami André
Chassaigne on lui reprochant de poser la
légitimité de la rue à celle du
Parlement mais vous qui aimez vous
rappelez votre passé de gauche dois-je
vous rappeler que c'est la grève et la
rue qui ont bâti des conquêtes sociales
sans remonter jusqu'à 1789
contestez-vous les grèves de 1906 pour
la journée de travail à 8h
contestez-vous la légitimité des grèves
de 1936 et la victoire des congés payés
contestez-vous les formidables progrès
suite au mouvement de 68 à sa grève
massive à la mobilisation de la jeunesse
enfin plus proche de nous les victoires
de 95 face à la réforme des retraites de
Monsieur Juppé de 2006 pour effacer le
CPE non-elle pas confirmé la force du
mouvement social et sa légitimité oui
madame la Première ministre il existe
une légalité résultant d'une élection
mais il existe une légitimité sociale
que vous ne pouvez pas nier et qui
aujourd'hui s'imposent à vous oui le
recul de l'âge du départ à la retraite
est refusé par notre peuple vous avez
fait un choix de société un choix de
droites un choix de classe le débat eu
au moins le mérite de clarifier
l'échiquier politique l'Union des
droites de renaissance à LR minoritaire
électoralement ensemble vous avez pris
les reines par un acte d'autoritarisme
dangereux pour la démocratie que devrait
confirmer la CMP réunis depuis ce matin
madame la Première ministre nous ne le
serons pas faire nous ne lâcherons rien
y compris avec les moyens
constitutionnels qui sont à notre
disposition
merci
pour vos répondre la parole est à madame
la Première ministre Madame Élisabeth
borne merci monsieur Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Eliana Sassi il y a quelque
chose de grave à opposé systématiquement
la légitimité de la rue à celle du
Parlement
il y a quelque chose de dangereux à
tenté par tout moyen d'empêcher le débat
de le bloquer
[Applaudissements]
la gauche sénatoriale la gauche
sénatoriale a revendiqué un seul
objectif empêcher un vote sur le texte
vous n'avez pas réussi de longs débat
ont eu lieu tous les articles ont été
examinés et le projet de loi a été
adopté à une large majorité
madame la Présidente assassin évidemment
j'aurais préféré plus de débats de fonds
et moins de procédures plus de débats
d'idées et moins de posture vous en avez
décidé autrement je le regrette mais
c'est ainsi et c'est le fait unique de
ce qui devient la nuit Pesse sénatoriale
[Applaudissements]
je veux
je veux à cet égard
je veux à cet égard salut et l'attitude
responsable de la majorité sénatoriale
pour la bonne tenue des discussions dans
l'émission
vous avez pu vous pencher
vous avez pu vous pencher sur tous les
articles et enrichir le texte de
nombreuses propositions notamment pour
améliorer les pensions des femmes ou en
faveur de l'emploi des seniors vous avez
également pu faire votre de nombreux
amendements déposés lors de l'examen à
l'Assemblée madame la Présidente assis
quand j'entends certains parlementaires
de la nupes qualifié le processus
démocratique en cours de prise d'otages
des Français j'y vois une entreprise de
disqualification de nos institutions
particulièrement insupportables venant
des lieux de la nation
[Applaudissements]
pour ma part j'ai le plus grand respect
pour le travail parlementaire qui se
poursuit en ce moment même en commission
mixte paritaire
et je suis convaincu que le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale peuvent s'accorder
pour empirer à l'écart de pension entre
les femmes et les hommes qui augmentera
les petites retraites qui fermera les
principaux régimes spéciaux qui
améliorera l'emploi des seniors qui
protégera ceux qui sont
usés par le travail qui permettra à ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt de
partir plus tôt cette réforme est
nécessaire elle a été enrichie notamment
grâce aux travaux de votre assemblée et
avec mon gouvernement nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés pour que dans les
prochains jours une majorité vote la
réforme des retraites je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame
Samantha casse
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole
madame la ministre des Sports
pas mars un baromètre national des
pratiques sportives pour l'année 2022
dont les résultats sont très
encourageants 60% des Français de 15 ans
et plus ont pratiqué une activité
physique et sportive en moyenne une fois
par semaine au cours des 12 dernières 12
derniers mois soit 6 points de plus
qu'en 2018 malheureusement ces résultats
ont pu être occultés par les profondes
crises de gouvernance qu'on traversait
certaines institutions du sport français
depuis quelques années notamment les
fédérations françaises de rugby et de
football le sport est vecteur d'unités
et d'émancipation il rend possible une
société rassemblée autour de valeurs
essentielles telles que l'équité
l'esprit d'équipe l'inclusion le respect
et la persévérance et rien ne doit
entacher le projet politique et sociétal
qu'il porte en lui alors que la France
se prépare à accueillir des événements
sportifs mondiaux majeurs la Coupe du
monde de rugby à la fin de l'année et
les olympiques et paralympique à l'été
2024 il apparaît donc nécessaire de
promouvoir des valeurs sportives
irréprochables ma question madame la
ministre porte sur la réforme de la
gouvernance des fédérations sportives un
comité national pour renforcer l'éthique
dans le sport vient d'être créé et ses
membres vient d'être désignés
pourriez-vous préciser quel va être le
fonctionnement de ce comité ainsi que
ses missions précises et ses objectifs
merci pour vos répondre la parole que la
ministre des Sports des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques madame Amélie oudia
Castéra vous avez la parole
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Samantha casbone en effet les
derniers mois ont été marqués par une
série de crises dans le sport français
qui ont mis en exergue la nécessité
d'améliorer la gouvernance de ce sport
et notamment des fédérations sportives
mais
il est clair absolument clair que ses
errements constataient ne peuvent pas se
reproduire s'achissant d'organisation
qui sont délégataires d'une mission de
service public et qui ont la
responsabilité d'une partie de notre
jeunesse mais il est clair aussi merci
d'avoir rappelé que ça ne doit pas
éluder les progrès dans la pratique
sportive l'engagement remarquable des
bénévoles des éducateurs sportives et
aussi que beaucoup de fédérations vont
bien avancent bien ainsi que les progrès
la démocratie sportive qui ont été
notamment impulsées par la loi du 2 mars
2022 qui a instauré la parité au niveau
des instances dirigeantes du sport
français et aussi permis le vote des
clubs pour les assembler général
électives maintenant cette amélioration
de la gouvernance il faut la prolonger
la poursuivre l'amplifier c'est le sens
de ce comité national pour renforcer
l'éthique et la démocratie dans le sport
que j'ai mis en place qui va être qu'aux
présidé par Marie-George Buffet et par
Stéphane diaganin il va être composé de
10 autres personnalités qualifiées
incontestable venant d'horizon divers je
pense à Jean-François l'amour je pense à
Arsène Wenger je pense à notre arbitre
pionnière Stéphanie frappard je pense
aussi à une grande dame comme Isabelle
Autissier ce comité aura la
responsabilité de me faire des
propositions pour l'automne prochain en
faisant un très grand nombre d'auditions
et il aura la responsabilité à l'automne
de me livrer un certain nombre de
conclusions autour de trois axes une
gouvernance du sport qui soit plus
éthique plus démocratique avec plus de
débats plus de pluralisme et aussi plus
protectrice des pratiquantes et des
pratiquants notamment sur la thématique
des violences à caractère sexistes et
sexuels je vous remercie merci bonhomme
demi
la parole est à notre collègue Rémi
Cardon pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains il y avait la
parole
madame est la première ministre monsieur
du stop disait Thiers devant les députés
je le cite pour atteindre le port il
faut un cap ce cap progrès justice
équilibre pour nos retraites nous le
cherchons toujours et ce n'est pas le
simulac de démocratie que vous avez
offert au Parlement qui nous a permis de
nous en a rapprocher premièrement les
retraités ne verront jamais leur 1200
euros une homme de pension de retraite
longtemps promise
voilà votre vision vision du progrès
deuxièmement les femmes continueront de
toucher des pensions de retraite
inférieure à celle des hommes en moyenne
39%, voilà votre vision de la justice
troisièmement vous faites reposer tous
les efforts sur une seule génération
sans jamais solliciter le patronat voilà
votre vision de l'équilibre madame la
Première ministre une chose est sûre
nous ne partageons pas le même cap et
nous sommes des millions à refuser
d'embarquer avec la droite sénatoriale
sur ce radeau de la Méduse vous faites
l'unanimité et l'unité contre vous
l'unanimité des syndicats des
travailleurs des millions de personnes
qui descendent dans les rues chaque
semaine qui votent la réduction des
grèves la reconduction et qu'il
lâcheront rien
j'aimerais vous demander madame la
Première ministre finalement pour qui et
avec qui gouvernez-vous
ce que vous proposez consciemment ou
inconsciemment d'ailleurs c'est
l'alternative mortifère à savoir la
préparation du terrain à la prise de
pouvoir du rassemblement national
bref il me reste à vous demander madame
la Première ministre êtes-vous des
inconscients ou des irresponsables
pour vous répondre la parole
est top ministre du Travail du plein
emploi d'insertion vous avez la parole
merci à Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur cardan vous dites que vous
ne partagez pas votre sentiment que vous
ne partagez pas notre effort nous nous
sommes convaincus que cette réforme a
une majorité cette réforme a une
majorité parce que elle peut être votée
par tous ceux et toutes celles qui
souhaitent sauver et préserver le
système par répartition cette réforme a
aussi une majorité parce qu'elle peut
être votée par tous ceux qui sont prêts
à aménager et faire en sorte de mieux
protéger à la fois ceux qu'on les
carrières les plus longues mais aussi
ceux qui ont les métiers les plus
exposés à l'usure professionnelle et à
la pénibilité cette réforme elle a une
majorité parce que celle de ceux qui
veulent la voter sont ceux qui veulent
faire en sorte que l'emploi des seniors
soit amélioré dans notre pays puis nous
ayons un taux d'activités qui puisse
augmenter et cette réforme elle sera
aussi votée par ceux qui sont attachés à
la revalorisation des petites retraites
vous en faites un cheval de bataille
monsieur le sénateur c'est la
démonstration que la gauche aujourd'hui
est déconnectée des classes populaires
avec cette réforme ce sont un million
800000 retraités actuels qui vont
bénéficier d'une revalorisation pouvant
aller de 25 à 100 euros ce sont 900 000
parmi eux qui vont bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de 70 à 100 euros par
mois et monsieur le sénateur nous
parlons de retraités
par mois si vous considérez que une
augmentation de 70-80 ou 90 euros par
mois ça n'est rien pour eux c'est que
vous avez perdu le sens de la réalité
vous nous dites que nous serions
inconscients et responsables les
responsabilité dans votre camp elle est
dans votre camp quand vous ne faites
rien alors que le système est en train
de s'écrouler elle est en son temps elle
est dans votre camp quand vous faites
rien alors que ce que notre réforme
permet de sauver le système par
répartition Monsieur le Sénateur pendant
le débat dont vous n'avez visiblement
pas retenu grand chose vous avez eu des
mots assez outrancier comme vous en avez
à l'instant à l'égard de la Premier
ministre c'est la démonstration monsieur
le sénateur que la mélanchonisation des
esprits que j'ai évoqués elle vous a
gagné comme elle gagne l'ensemble de la
gauche française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre majorité c'est tout simplement
49-3
monsieur ministre si vous voulez en tout
cas sachez gouverner sans le peuple et
contre lui et ses représentants c'est
dangereux pour la démocratie c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec le groupe
socialiste nous allons déposer une
demande de riz pour sauver la démocratie
pour sauver la République de vos Bayons
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Marc Philippe de Bryce pour le
groupe les républicains
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique les la récente publication
des chiffres de la construction neuve
pour 2022 confirme ce que nous n'avons
cessé de dire depuis plusieurs mois à
plusieurs ici au gouvernement la
situation n'est pas dramatique elle est
catastrophique
rarement on a connu des chiffres aussi
dramatiques moins 25% pour les
promoteurs privés - 30% pour les
constructions individuelles 350
000 unités prévues en 2023 pour mémoire
après le plan de relance de Jean-Louis
Borloo on était à
486040% de moins annoncé pour l'année
qui vient et ça va continuer des
faillites en cascade sont annoncés dans
la promotion pour le logement social la
réforme Funès des aPL de la loi Elan a
assécher les finances des offices d'HLM
et on est pour la troisième année
consécutive en dessous des 100 000
logements sociaux
sans parler des mesures que vous avez
prises sur un certain nombre de sujets
par exemple zéro artificialisation net
heureusement que le Sénat est en train
de les corriger donc monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple est-ce
que vous avez prévu enfin un plan de
relance pour relancer la construction
neuve dans notre pays comme nous l'avons
fait avec succès sous Nicolas Sarkozy
Jackson qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu
des mesures fiscales de relance
exceptionnelle comme nous avons réussi à
le faire sous le gouvernement de
François Fillon pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Marc-Philippe de
Bresse d'abord quelques chiffres très
récents et qui seront l'occasion de
d'objectiver les choses on a une
augmentation des autorisations
en 2022 qui remonte à un niveau que nous
n'avions pas connu depuis plus de 6 ans
à plus de 480 000 en Hauses de 3% mais
dans le même temps on a une baisse des
mises en chantier de 3% à 376000 avec
les indications que vous donnez entre
les deux on a des phénomènes structurels
je vais revenir mais on a aussi un
phénomène conjoncturel qui est la très
forte augmentation des refus de prêt
dans un double contexte ou globalement
les taux d'intérêt sont passés de 1,5 à
3-20 sur 20 ans et ou dans le même temps
le coût moyen de la construction a
augmenté avec un effet d'inflation
généralisé en 2022 particulièrement vrai
dans le champ du logement premier sujet
à côté de ça par rapport à cette
question des prêts et de la baisse de la
demande puisque nous avons eu
39% de baisse de la demande au dernier
trimestre et ça c'est pas un sujet
gouvernemental la baisse de la demande
elle est liée à des acheteurs qui
cessent d'acheter pas à une absence
d'offre
la réforme du taux d'usure en faisant en
sorte de la mensualiser depuis le
premier février pour fluidifier une
partie du marché le premier élément de
réponse les réponses plus structurelles
elles seront prises dans la continuité
du CNR logement qui se termine au mois
d'avril nous discutons en ce moment avec
tous les professionnels vous en avez
cité un certain nombre il y en a
d'autres et dans ces autres il y a les
élus l'ambition du président de la
République c'est d'ouvrir le chantier de
la décentralisation du logement vous
connaissez parfaitement ces questions
vous les avez connus comme édules
locales vous les avez connus comme
membres du gouvernement on a eu
l'habitude de réfléchir sur un combien
là où la disparité des situations fait
que c'est le ou et le comment qui mérite
d'être questionné et la décentralisation
du logement elle est au cœur d'une
ambition y compris sur la rénovation
énergétique dans un dialogue franc avec
les communes avec les intercommunalités
et avec les départements changements des
zonage des centralisations des
dispositifs soutient aux maires
bâtisseurs ce sont ces ensembles sur
lesquels nous travaillons
monsieur dobresse
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
j'ai été en son temps mini du logement
il faut que vous révisiez vos chiffres
les notaires viennent de sortir le
dernier chiffre pour le dernier
trimestre 2022 par rapport il y a un an
c'est moins 25% les permis de construire
monsieur le ministre moi 25% annoncé je
vais prendre un seul chiffre si vous
rapportez le nombre de constructions
nobles à la population nombre de ménages
français c'est le plus bas chiffres que
nous allons connaître depuis 1951 ça
avait donné l'appel de l'abbé Pierre
monsieur le ministre vous sous-estimer
le problème parce que vous êtes
confronté à des objectifs stratégiques
contradictoires il est grand temps que
le gouvernement se réveille
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
Concorde pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues
Haïti pleurant tous les jours c'est mort
c'est blessé par dizaines Haïti affamé a
été livré au mait de gang haïté
assistant au viol de ses femmes Haïti
voyant ses enfants recrutés par des
groupes armés Haïti sans gouvernement
sans État s'enfonce inexorablement dans
le chaos et pourtant pas un mot de
l'État sur la situation de ce pays à qui
nous sommes tendre ce pays envers lequel
nous avons une dette morale comme le
disait si légitimement François Hollande
en 2015 première colonie noire à prendre
son indépendance en 1804 Haïti a bien
des égards à ouvrir des chemins
repousser les limites du possible et ce
alors même qu'elle a été dès le départ
affublé du fardeau indigne d'une dette
insoutenable pour acheter sa liberté la
résolution adoptée par l'ONU en octobre
dernier constitué un pas symbolique mais
ne peut servir de ref pour justifier
lorsqu'une action collective certains
pays comme le Canada ont fait le choix
d'une politique plus active que fait la
France à 1h30 de vol des pays français
d'Amérique que fait l'euro il faut
désormais aller plus loin que des
sanctions face au massacres des Haïtiens
devant le retrait des organisations
humanités qui baissent les bras une à
une il faut organiser la coopération
dans le bassin qui arrivait il faut oser
l'envoi d'une force de maintien de la
paix face au Massac quotidien de ces
villes haïtiens la tireur la famille
dans laquelle vit la population dans un
état désormais inexistant dois-je
rappeler qu'à la suite de l'assassinat
du président Moïse en 2017 Haïti n'a
plus de gouvernement combien de temps
encore allons-nous attendre combien de
morts encore combien d'heures combien de
viol combien de grammes avant d'agir
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste déléguée en charge du
commerce extérieur des Français de
l'étranger Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE monsieur
le ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice qu'on
cogne d'abord je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
sommes d'accord sur un point la
situation en Haïti qui a est très grave
à la fois sur le plan humanitaire sur le
plan sécurité et bien sûr sur le plan
politique en revanche il y a un point
sur lequel nous ne sommes pas d'accord
c'est l'inaction de la France aux côtés
des États-Unis et du Canada la France
est active c'est l'une des nations les
plus actives pour tenter d'aider les
Haïtiens nous le faisons notamment dans
le cadre du soutien à la police
nationale haïtienne et nous allons
encore accroître cette coopération et ce
soutien nous le faisons également dans
le cadre de l'aide humanitaire 8,5
millions d'euros d'aide humanitaires
dont 5 millions d'aides alimentaires qui
va directement aux Haïtiens enfin nous
sommes vous l'avez dit actif dans le
cadre de la diplomatie au niveau des
Nations unies dans le cadre de la
résolution
26 53 pour infliger les sanctions au
criminels qui sont les auteurs de ce que
vous dénonciez à l'instant notamment
ceux des gang enfin nous sommes à
l'écoute de nos partenaires s'agissant
du projet de force internationale
d'appui à la police nationale haïtienne
sur la forme qu'elle pourrait prendre et
nous pouvons envisager d'y apporter un
soutien matériel et puis je voudrais
enfin terminer par le fait que la sortie
de crise implique et vous le savez un
accord inclusif entre les acteurs
politiques haïtiens la mise en place
récente du Haut Conseil de transition
doit permettre d'avancer vers des
élections comme prévu dans le document
de consensus national du 21 décembre
dernier c'est en tout cas ce que nous
souhaitons pour le bien d'Haïti merci
madame cocotte vous avez quelques
secondes
je ne peux que diplôer
la discrétion la très grande discrétion
des actions que vous venez d'énumérer
mais c'est vrai Haïti n'alli pétrole ni
gaz
la parole est à notre collègue Catherine
Dumas pour le groupe les républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur depuis plus
d'une semaine Paris est devenu une ville
submergée par des montagnes de déchets
et oui mes chers collègues je ne vous
apprends rien je pense
cette mille tonnes de poubelles non
ramassées une recondition de la grève
qui est annoncée jusqu'au 20 mars alors
cette situation peut entraîner des
risques sanitaires conséquents bien sûr
aggravé par la recrudescence de la
présence des rats appelé les surmulots à
Paris dans les espaces publics de la
capitale monsieur le ministre les
Parisiens sont en colère pourtant
l'Amérique Paris personne ne semble s'en
émouvoir madame Hidalgo a même annoncé
son soutien entier et total au mouvement
social
et oui c'est la vérité constatant cette
inertie la chef de fil de l'opposition à
Paris madame Rachida Dati vous a saisi
hier vous avez donc chargé monsieur le
ministre le préfet de police de demander
à la mère de Paris de réquisitionner les
moyens matériels et en personnels
nécessaires au ramassage des poubelles
en réponse ce matin le premier adjoint
de Madame Hidalgo affirme que c'est le
gouvernement qui a créé cette situation
quelle mauvaise volonté alors Monsieur
le Ministre quand l'État va-t-il se
substituer à la mairie de Paris pour
régler cette situation et surtout dans
quel délai
pour vous répondre
la parole d'un monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les outre-mer monsieur
Darmanin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice vous connaissez déjà
tout à la suite de 9 jours de grève et
chacun a pu constater qu'il soit
parisien d'occasion ou parisiens
d'habitude l'annoncellement dans
certains arrondissements de Paris d'un
certain nombre de poubelles que vous
avez qualifiez-vous de plusieurs
milliers de tonnes posent des questions
pour la sécurité évidemment de nos
concitoyens ou même d'ailleurs où il y a
des manifestations mais pose aussi des
questions de salubrité publique que
chacun peut constater et pour avoir été
comme beaucoup ici gestionnaire d'une
collectivité locale chacun peut voir ce
que c'est qu'attendre 9 jours et voir
des milliers de tonnes d'ordures et de
poubelles effectivement être sur la voie
publique j'ai donc demandé mais au nom
de la salubrité publique puisque mise à
l'intérieur est en charge d'un tutelle
sur le préfet de police et préfecture de
police et après avoir contacté
évidemment Madame la Maire de Paris
après avoir été saisi vous avez évoqué
Madame Dati en effet par plusieurs mères
d'arrondissement mais aussi par
plusieurs élus parisiens quelle que soit
leur bord politique après avoir été
saisi par eux j'ai donc demandé à Madame
Hidalgo d'abord évidemment à l'oral et
ensuite ce matin par la terminale
préfecture de police par écrit de
pouvoir faire ce que le droit lui permet
de faire notamment que la mairie de
Paris a fait pendant 10 de la loi
travail puisque il y a déjà eu
effectivement une situation similaire de
réquisitionner la question qui relève à
la fois du relèvement du des poubelles
qui sont relevées pardon de l'espace
public comme de l'incinération parce
qu'il s'agit bien des deux sujets à
l'oral j'ai entendu en effet ce matin le
premier adjoint évoqué le fait qu'il ne
serait pas favorable à cette situation
j'attends évidemment que Madame la Maire
de Paris réponde par écrit à la demande
par écrit du préfet de police et si ce
soir cette confirmation est faite la
mairie de Paris ne prenait pas ses
responsabilités je le dis ce soir demain
matin au plus tard le préfet de police
propose possédera réquisition
au nom de la salubrité publique et je
crois que tous les parisiens quel que
soit ce qu'ils pensent de la réforme des
retraites en seront heureux
madame Dumas
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
de votre réponse c'est vrai qu'à chaque
grève Paris s'enfonce un peu plus dans
l'insalubrité dans laquelle Anne Hidalgo
et ses alliés ont plongé les Parisiens
nous sommes aujourd'hui à moins de 500
jours de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
l'image de notre pays et de sa capitale
est durablement dégradée auprès des
touristes et des observateurs étrangers
qui sont sidérés il est donc grand temps
d'agir merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au président Laurent
Laffont pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
porte sur le devenir du Stade de France
et s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
Sports des Jeux Olympiques et olympiques
madame la ministre vous avez annoncé il
y a quelques jours que l'État
travaillait dans deux directions soit la
session du Stade de France soit le
renouvellement d'un système de
concession déjà en vigueur depuis 25 ans
le gouvernement n'a pas arrêté à ce jour
son choix entre ces deux options qui
sont significativement différentes de
fait le Trésor a engagé de manière
inédite deux procédures parallèles l'une
pouvant aboutir à la vente du Stade de
France l'autre pouvant aboutir au
renouvellement de système de concession
alors que les deux procédures sont
lancées les objectifs du gouvernement
quant à l'avenir du Stade de France
n'apparaissent pas encore clairement
aussi madame la ministre je souhaite
vous poser quatre questions précises
pour que vous nous éclairiez sur les
intentions
du gouvernement la première avez-vous eu
des engagements de la part des deux
principales fédérations sportives
utilisatrices du Stade de France le
football et le rugby quand à une
intégration à minima du stade et dans
quelles conditions financières le
souhaite-t-elle le faire la deuxième
question porte sur l'athlétisme qui
n'apparaît plus dans les consultations
lancées par le Trésor les deux dernières
portent enfin sur la scission concernant
la session pourriez-vous nous préciser
quels sont les critères qui pourraient
vous amener à choisir la session plutôt
que la concession et enfin dernière
question est-ce que l'État français
serait prêt à vendre le Stade de France
à une structure appartement appartenant
pardon à un État étranger Stade de
France qui est devenu depuis la Coupe du
Monde de 98 et avec les Jeux Olympiques
dans quelques mois un emblème du sport
français
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre sport des Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques madame houdéac vous avez
la parole
en amont de la fin de la concession à
l'été 2025 le gouvernement s'est donné
une boussole qui est de faire émerger le
meilleur projet de long terme avec
méthode et transparence pour le Stade de
France avec deux exigences préserver la
vocation sportive du stade et une
deuxième qui est de préserver les
intérêts économiques et financiers de
l'État alors vous l'avez dit deux
procédures ont été lancées en parallèle
vous m'avez posé quatre questions
précises je vais essayer d'y répondre
s'agissant des fédérations elles sont
libres de candidater elles sont libres
de s'associer à un candidat ils sont
libres de négocier les conditions
d'utilisation du stade ce qui est
important c'est qu'elle puisse échanger
avec l'ensemble des candidats dans le
respect de l'équité et du droit de la
concurrence s'agissant de la piste
d'athlétisme les deux avis
précisent bien mentionne bien la
capacité d'accueillir des grands
événements sportifs
internationaux l'athlétisme est un
exemple et là il faudra voir ce que
proposeront les candidats s'agissant des
meilleures solutions et des meilleures
options prises sur ce terrain des grands
événements sportifs sur les différents
critères il y en a deux qui sont
expressément posés dans les deux avis un
critère davantage économique global pour
l'État et un critère qui est plus
commercial et technique relatif
notamment à l'amélioration de l'accueil
du stade et notamment de l'attractivité
de ce stade dans son territoire
s'agissant de votre question sur un
investisseur étranger s'il devait y en
avoir un qui réponde aux conditions
protectrices qui dans le cas d'une
session serait de toute façon fixée par
la loi et Parlement ou si il devait cet
investisseur étranger participer à un
groupement plus simplement d'opérateurs
il n'y a pas de raison de l'en empêcher
de l'écarter a priori et par principe
mais ce que je veux vraiment dire c'est
projet ambitieux de long terme à la
hauteur de la place de ce stade dans le
récit sportif national des attentes des
élus et des habitants de ce territoire
je vous remercie
monsieur Lafont
la parole est à notre collègue Frédéric
puissat pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur
500 jours c'est le nombre de jours qu'il
nous reste avant la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux olympiques de Paris
la parade nautique ou des fils ronds les
10000 athlètes sur 6 km est un lourd des
filles en matière de sécurité le budget
que leur annoncé maîtrisée à hauteur de
8 milliards d'euros sans de plus en plus
difficile à tenir et la France n'a pas
droit à l'erreur mais ma question porte
sur une autre difficulté celle qui
concerne la situation et la capacité
d'accueil des hôpitaux pendant que ce
dérouleront les Jeux Olympiques cet été
pour ce qui concerne les 15000 athlètes
et ceux qui les accompagnent un centre
de santé sera créé en lien avec l'APHP
mais pour ce qui concerne les plus de 10
millions de visiteurs attendus que
compte faire le gouvernement les
hôpitaux de Parisiens ont en normal
peine à fonctionner les services
d'urgence sont débordés et trop de lits
de chirurgie sont aujourd'hui fermés
ajoutons de surcroît qu'en plein été en
raison des congés les équipes médicales
sont réduites gouverner c'est prévoir
alors sur le ministre qu'avez-vous prévu
pour assurer le fonctionnement des
hôpitaux parisiens pour faire face aux
soins courants et à l'affût de visiteurs
pendant les Jeux Olympiques merci pour
vous répondre la parole et communiste de
la santé de la prévention Monsieur
François Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice puissant autour de la première
ministre le gouvernement est totalement
mobilisé autour de la ministre des
Sports pour faire de la Coupe du monde
de rugby également mais des Jeux
Olympiques bien entendu et paralympiques
la grande fête sportive qui doivent être
alors dans ce cadre plus global mon
mystère est concentré sur trois points
vous en avez appelé un j'en préciserai
deux autres le premier c'est bien sûr de
maintenir l'accès aux soins l'accès aux
soins sur les territoires concernés par
les Jeux Olympiques que ce soit à
l'Île-de-France mais n'oublions pas
aussi les hauts de France et PACA qui
vont être directement concernés cet
accès aux soins il est pour les
Franciliens par exemple bien entendu des
gens qui habitent à côté des sites
olympiques et pour cela nous mobilisons
le public le privé la médecine libérale
l'ensemble de nos partenaires pour
pouvoir assurer cette réponse qui a
évaluée vous parliez des services
d'urgence nous évaluons à plus 5% de
fréquentation pendant cette période à
titre d'exemple
les trois autres publics sont
particulièrement alterner nous sommes
attentifs au touristes qui vont arriver
à ce moment-là il y a des questions de
prise en charge bien sûr financière mais
il y a aussi des questions de traduction
qu'il faut prendre en compte les
sportifs et leur staff ont des parcours
de soins qui vont être identifiés pour
une croise pas les publics de
spectateurs et puis enfin les personnes
en situation de handicap doivent
bénéficier de parcours de soins
parfaitement identifié le deuxième point
que nous travaillons c'est celui des
situations sanitaires exceptionnelles le
risque climatique nous serons en été les
risques infectieux les risques
nerbaissés et le risque également de
cybersécurité de cyberaca avec la mise
en place de contre-mesures enfin le
troisième point c'est celui de
l'héritage des Jeux Olympiques cet
héritage c'est le sport santé le
président de la République a annoncé que
2024 le sport serait grande cause
nationale dans ce cadre-là le
déploiement encore plus important du
sport santé en termes de prévention
puisque c'est un axe fort de la
politique de mon ministère va nous
permettre d'améliorer l'état de santé
globale de nos concitoyens voici les
trois axes sur lesquels nous travaillons
actuellement de façon extrêmement
précise je vous remercie
préventive parce que les Français ont
trop souffert du fiasco du Stade de
France à l'occasion de la finale de la
Ligue des champions alors c'est vrai que
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
comme le président de la République nous
souhaitons des médailles mais nous
souhaitons surtout être sur les plus
hautes marches du podium en matière
d'organisation organisation des Jeux
Olympiques organisations de la santé
pendant les Jeux Olympiques organisation
de la santé aussi dans nos territoires
et dans nos départements au quotidien
pour tous les Français merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
durant pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez écrit
le 3 mars au fonctionnaire de police
pour répondre aux inquiétudes qui se
sont exprimées derrière le slogan sauver
la PJ de Clémenceau ce courrier a été
rédigé avant même que le rapport du
Sénat soit rendu public la mission que
j'ai eu l'honneur de mener avec ma
collègue Nadine belureau au nom de la
commission des lois avait pourtant émis
22 recommandations adopté à l'unanimité
pour vous aider à faire cette réforme
nécessaire vous ne les avez pas entendu
vous les avez d'ailleurs à peine attendu
vous vouliez aller vite mais vous n'avez
pas réussi à rassurer les péjistes qui
continuent à exprimer publiquement leur
écureuiland vous deviez restaurer
l'attractivité de la filière PJ vous
confortez des envies d'émissions vous
n'avez pas davantage rassurer les
avocats les magistrats qui se joineront
au péjiste demain partout en France pour
manifester devant les tribunaux mais
surtout vous n'avez répondu à aucun des
quatre rapports qui ont été rendus sur
le sujet les inspections ont évoqué
l'insuffisance du cadrage initial de
l'expérimentation notre collègue
Dominati pour la commission des finances
vous appelez à ne pas déshabiller la PJ
à l'Assemblée nationale des deux
rapporteurs n'ont pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord monsieur bernalicis craignant
une mise à mal du principe
d'indépendance de la police judiciaire
ici enfin au Sénat où nous avons proposé
un moratoire jusqu'aux Jeux Olympiques
il vous permettrait d'améliorer votre
copie tout en évitant de fragiliser
notre appareil sécuritaire avant
l'échéance de 2024 pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre avait vous rejeté ce conseil
éclairé du Sénat
de la parole est obéissent de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin
merci Monsieur Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les reins merci pour votre
question permettez-moi de vous dire
d'abord que c'est une réforme très
importante que celle de la réforme de la
police nationale vous-même vous l'avez
souligné dans votre rapport avec Madame
bellurou comme l'Assemblée nationale la
souligné puisque depuis 60 ans il n'y a
pas eu de réformes de la police
nationale à ce point structurantes et en
effet elle faisait des interrogations
des questions et bien sûr bouscu des
habitudes auxquelles le ministère
d'intérieur et singulièrement le
ministre que je suis et particulièrement
attentif je constate d'ailleurs que le
Sénat dans sa très grande majorité
vous-même d'ailleurs un cycle groupe
socialiste a adopter le principe de
cette réforme puisque vous avez voté
vous le savez bien la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et je crois de la vocaux
construite ensemble saguièrement sur la
question de la réforme de la police
nationale alors vous dites que nous
n'avons pas pris connaissance et compte
de vos propositions permettez-moi de
dire monsieur le sénateur que c'est faux
il est vrai que j'ai refusé d'attendre
la fin des Jeux Olympiques pour mettre
en place une réforme qui est travaillée
depuis le ministre Jox ce qui ne
rajeunira pas grand monde ici bien
évidemment et qui travailleurs et
travailler depuis plus de deux ans et
demi par le ministre de l'Intérieur que
je suis qui avait déjà été imaginé par
mes prédécesseurs dans le fameux Livre
Blanc sur l'intégralité des autres
dispositions nous vous suivons monsieur
le sénateur les EPG devront
systématiquement être PJ bien sûr c'est
le cas la formation en particulier des
DPN est prévue nous avons travaillé avec
le ministre de la Justice bien sûr pour
que l'évaluation se fasse avec les
programmes de la République pour les
ddpn nous travaillons d'ailleurs avec
une lettre conjointe pour rappeler que
l'article 12 du code de procédure pénale
soit évidemment que les magistrats puis
saisir des services d'enquête et ce ne
sont pas des préfets qui le feront le
fait que nous serions au rendez-vous des
dzpn qui pourront travailler en lien
avec les dipn que j'évoquais dans le
courrier je pense que c'est au
rendez-vous également vous suggérer
l'état des lieux du stock des procédures
c'est notre proposition numéro une avec
les garder son nous avons confié une
mission suite notamment à vos
interpellations les moyens spécialisés
pour les directions régionales c'est
votre profession numéro 4 c'est
effectivement le cas les magistrats
devant saisir
directement les offices centraux c'est
déjà le cas faut conclure et oui
monsieur le Président j'attendais votre
rappel pour dire qu'à quel point je ne
peux citer toutes les bonnes
propositions que nous suivons de la part
du sénateur du Rhin
le ministre toutes ces bonnes
propositions ne sont pas tombées dans
l'oreille des pjistes et si nous vous
imprimons si nous exprimons une une
inquiétude c'est que notre conviction et
notre crainte c'est que sans PJ nous ne
gagnerons pas la guerre contre la drogue
sans PJ nous ne lutterons pas
efficacement contre la criminalité
organisée notamment économique et
financière nous craignons que la
dilution de l'expertise de l'APG que le
tout voit public ne soit une impasse
tout comme le rétrécissement
départemental et l'apprend la prise en
main de l'administratif sur le
judiciaire alors oui monsieur le
ministre comme les pjistes vous le
disent comme les magistraldies pour la
sécurité des Français sauver la PJ merci
la parole est à notre collègue bruno
Sido pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
la Cour des comptes dans son dernier
rapport préconise la réduction du nombre
de communes et notamment les plus
petites d'entre elles les gouvernements
successifs par le biais de différentes
lois se sont attaqués régulièrement au
nombre de communes en France toutefois
je tiens à rappeler que le fait comme
une fait des partenaires précèdent le
fait républicain la loi de
1971 dites-lois Marcelin a voulu faire
fusionner les communes sans grands
succès et d'autres lois similaires ont
été votées par la suite j'ajouterai que
comme on n'est pas prophète en son pays
monsieur mars solin a fait zéro fusion
association dans son département
par exemple dans mon département par
contre la Haute-Marne avec cette loi 200
communes ont souhaité au départ fusionné
mais la moitié d'entre elles ont divorcé
l'année suivante aujourd'hui les
communes sont attaquées sous l'angle
financier afin d'assainir les finances
publiques de l'État en se basant sur les
chiffres de 2021 année paradoxale où les
investissements des collectivités ont
été très réduits à cause de la crise
covid monsieur le ministre bien que ce
que de ce que dit la Cour des comptes
soit rarement entendu par les
gouvernements quel est votre position
sur l'analyse de ce qu'elle préconise
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bruno
à l'évocation du fait que ce Marcelin
n'a pas été prophète en son pays je veux
convoquer la présidente de roche le
sénateur pied-noir le sénateur Bigot et
le sénateur Emmanuel capuc puisque le
département du Maine-et-Loire et celui
dans lequel il y a eu le plus de fusion
de communes 48% des communes ont
fusionné au point qui nous restent 186
communes sur les 358 que nous avions
mais quand je vous aurais précisé qu'il
ne s'agit quand je vous aurais précisé
qu'il ne s'agit que de mariage d'amour
et que je vous aurais dit qu'en matière
de fusion je ne crois pas au mariage qui
ne sont pas des mariages d'amour je vous
aurais précisé ce qui est une partie de
ma philosophie en pensant qu'il faut pas
plaquer un modèle national sur ces
sujets les constats on les connaît les
constats c'est d'expliquer que nous
avions en 1790 44000 communes que nous
n'en avions que nous en avions encore
38000 en 1960 et qu'on est rendu que à
34000 et qu'il n'y a eu que 235 fusions
de communes depuis 2014
pourtant un certain nombre de PPL je
pense à la PPL CIDO je pense à la PPL
Gatel ce sont les forcés de regarder
comment donner un statut aux communes
associées aux communes déléguées pour
éviter que ce soit tout ou rien
notre conviction et j'associe Dominique
Faure dont vous savez l'attachement aux
communes en particulier aux communes
rurales en particulier c'est que rien
dans ce domaine ne se fera par la
contrainte
l'intercommunalité est une chance à
condition qu'on est les conférences des
maires et les packs de gouvernance dans
certains cas il faut rendre possible les
fusions en montrant ce qu'elles
permettent mais il ne faut pas qu'elle
soit forcée sinon elles aboutissent à la
fin à des choses qui sont plus mauvaises
quelle doit être notre obsession c'est
faire en sorte qu'on ait des
mutualisations qui permettent
d'améliorer la vie des habitants sur le
territoire et le meilleur usage des
deniers publics dans certains endroits
ça peut passer par des fusions dans
d'autres par des coopérations
intercommunales dans d'autres encore par
des modes d'association qui dépendent de
ce que les élus veulent on peut pas à la
fois expliquer qu'on leur fait confiance
et projeter un modèle qui serait le même
partout en faisant fille de notre
histoire et de nos réalités locales
monsieur
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre des
Français sont plus que jamais attachés
alors commune la crise des gilets jaunes
la crise sanitaire sont passées par là
et ont démontré l'importance de ces 500
000 élus qui travaillent qui
administrent leur commune les mers et
leurs adjoints les conseils municipaux
bien souvent tous ces élus sont
bénévoles et font même beaucoup les
travaux à titre gracieux rappelons-nous
ce couple mère préfère le premier
ministre Jean Castex vantait le mérite
des mers comme des piliers de la
République on les applaudissait pour
leur implication mais aujourd'hui face
au poids des finances publiques on
voudrait les sacrifier alors je voudrais
vous dire Monsieur le Ministre que votre
réponse ne va pas convaincue alors je
repose ma question allez vous faire
payer aux petites communes le laxisme
budgétaire du gouvernement en les
supprimant
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
piennois pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à la ministre de la
transition énergétique en l'espace d'une
année la problématique des coûts de
l'énergie vous le savez est devenu
crucial pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens nos entreprises et même nos
collectivités locales dans ce contexte
le Mans à légiférer c'est son rôle et la
loi du 16 août 2022 prévoit que le prix
de l'accès régulé à l'énergie nucléaire
historique la reine ne peut être
inférieure à 49,50 € du mégawattheure
désormais puis curieusement le
gouvernement a introduit l'obligation de
soumettre cette disposition à l'avis de
la Commission européenne ce que le
Conseil d'État dans son délibéré du 3
février dernier à formellement identifié
comme
inutile puisque ce prix de 49,50 € et
largement inférieur au prix du marché
et non seulement le gouvernement semble
être sourd à cette objection du Conseil
d'État mais vous n'avez à ce jour même
pas solliciter la Commission européenne
monsieur ou madame la ministre je ne
sais pas qui me répondra pouvez-vous
donner les raisons de cette surdité
gouvernementale matinée d'une procrastée
procrastination bien étonnante
alors pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué
en charge des petits des moyens
d'entreprises du commerce et de
l'artisanat
monsieur le sénateur pied-noir j'ai
l'honneur d'essayer de vous répondre ma
collègue la ministre Agnès et dans ce
moment même à l'Assemblée nationale sur
le projet de loi nucléaire et s'excuse
de son absence et pourquoi je vais
essayer de répondre à votre question
pertinente et technique avec les
éléments dont je dispose et je ne doute
pas qu'elle y apportera d'autres
éléments à la suite dans cette fin de
journée je vais quand même rappeler
indépendamment des procédures que vous
mentionnez de la saisine et des
réactions du Conseil d'État la
mobilisation du gouvernement français
à l'endroit de notre mix énergétique et
nos travaux en cours avec la Commission
européenne pour faire avancer aussi la
réforme du marché de de l'énergie vous
rappelez quand même à quel point nous
nous continuons à investir massivement
dans le nucléaire 4 à 5 milliards
d'euros par an au niveau 2df 50
milliards d'euros depuis 2015 pour le
grand carénage 6 EPR 2 pour 50 milliards
d'euros et à l'international vous le
savez avec incl n'a pas lésiné il a
recapitalisé par deux fois depuis 2015
EDF près de 4 milliards 2017 3 milliards
en 2022 et vous le savez nous
construisons des nouveaux réacteurs les
travaux sont en cours et nous l'avons
dit Agnès l'a dit l'État sera au
rendez-vous les Français dans cette
situation dans voler des prix de
l'électricité sont protégés face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie vous avez
mentionné l'arène qui peu importe ce
qu'en dit le Conseil d'État est quand
même un dispositif qui aujourd'hui
protège massivement nos concitoyens mais
aussi une bonne partie de nos
entreprises je pense aussi au bouclier
et tarifaires vous le savez aux aides
énergies je voudrais vous ajouter
quelques points nous n'avons rien lâché
sur la réforme du marché européen de
l'énergie après un an de travail et de
mobilisation notamment de Bruno Le Maire
mais aussi Daniel panier runachet la
Commission a proposé formellement une
réforme qui reprend trois demandes
françaises majeures à laquelle vous êtes
sensible des contrats pour les
producteurs et tous les consommateurs
pour que l'électricité soit vendue à un
prix proche des coûts de production
nationale l'éligibilité du nucléaire
assez contrats l'éligibilité des
installations existantes comme c'est le
cas pour la plupart des centrales en
France c'est une nouvelle encourageante
une bonne base de travail à cette heure
et notre objectif et qu'elle soit
adoptée cette année je vous remercie
monsieur piennois
[Applaudissements]
je sais l'implication du gouvernement
même si elle est récente en faveur de la
relance de la filière nucléaire de notre
pays mais cela passe par des moyens à
consolider pour notre outil industriel
qui doit accomplir cette ce programme
nucléaire à savoir EDF qui doit faire
face à une dette colossale de 64
milliards d'euros qui doit faire face à
un mur d'investissement dans les années
à venir et cela l'ucrémont déclarait
lui-même que ce ne sera pas possible si
le prix de la reine reste fixé à 42
euros du megawater Agnès reconnaissait
elle-même que le prix de production par
EDF était aux alentours de 58 euros donc
on va bien qu'il y a un delta qui qui
est important et je demande au
gouvernement un minimum de cohérence
vous savez qu'il est encore temps de
prendre les mesures nécessaires d'une
part pour ne plus bafouer les décisions
du Parlement de piétiner ses décisions
vous avez actuellement je vous le
rappelle un véhicule législatif à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vous permet de
les faire de le faire je vous invite à
vous en saisir merci merci
[Applaudissements]
au gouvernement merci madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
de la promotion de loi visant adapter la
défense extérieure contre l'incendie à
la réalité des territoires ruraux la
séance est suspendue